all right brooklyn's best pizza and
pasta the sponsors of this next segment
continues to serve slices and the
community here's how
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome back to brooklyn's best so as
you know this weekend is halloween we
got a bunch of things going on if you
come in on halloween day
in your costume you get a free slice of
pizza you can pick anything in the case
other than that we're doing some family
specials
[Music]
[Applause]
you get three half trays of food you can
get lasagna you get a house salad you
get garlic nuts or you can get a chicken
parmesan with spaghetti you can get
baked ziti you can get spaghetti
meatballs salad and garlic nuts other
than that we got some great game day
specials we got two pies two cheese pies
for 26.95
we also have a cheese pie and wings for
29.95 we always have our same day two
slice and a drink special for 7.95 so
we've been open for three years now
uh we do a lot for our community we help
the schools out we've been doing a lot
of fundraisers lately
one of them is that we just started a
lunch program where
i'm here at five o'clock in the morning
busting out those kids lunches we got
125 lunches every monday this year
the best of las vegas just ended
hopefully we did well but the last two
years we've won
many awards uh
best pizza best italian best casual
restaurant and most importantly best
family restaurant and by the way we are
hiring we're opening up our second
location it's going to be downtown near
the arts district uh i-15 and charleston
we need
not that we need experienced people we
need great people talented people most
importantly good people come join us who
wants to be part of something special
what do you say kendall forget about it
we love it there all right thank you
brooklyn's best pizza and pasta for
sponsoring this segment give them a call
at
702-786-0103 and remember that special
offer get a large cheese with 10 wings
for 29.95 on game days and the family
pasta special is any pasta protein bread
and salad for just 49.95 that looks good
right i'll send it to you